I just always loved Liam Neeson is he a
good guy to work with oh my God and he
became a great he was a great drinking
buddy like the gray right yeah yeah we
were both we you know he's a big dude
he's like six six and uh we would kill
six bottles of wine him and I
and we would walk back to our hotel and
I would have to carry I need to Lean on
Me Liam on you Liam
on me
I could just see him drunk it's like uh
I'm so drunk now I can't ah what was
that higher so Frankie we should have
one more scoop we should I'm like yeah
Liam you're Liam Neeson we could have as
many scoops as you want how was he the
next day oh he's fine he can just drink
and be fine what a constitution and then
he stopped he just stopped I love it I
love Remy too what are your other kids
names Liam after Liam Neeson really
before I met Liam Neeson uh real quick I
took my pregnant wife at the time to see
The Crucible on Broadway with Liam
Neeson and Laura Linney and I'm a father
junkie like I always I'm always looking
for who could have been my father right
right and out comes this gigantic
beautiful Liam Neeson and I watch and
it's one of my favorite plays and I
watch him and I look at my wife who's
half Irish and I go we're naming the kid
Liam so we name him Liam after Liam
Neeson right years later I do worry I
get a call from Joe carnan I got a movie
called The Gray no matter what your
agents say you're in this movie just
know this right calls me up and goes I
want you to come and sit with me and
Liam I said Liam who goes Liam Neeson
he's playing that way so I go up and I
meet with them we get shit-faced and
it's a little bar on the Upper West Side
by his house and at like four o'clock in
the morning I said I gotta tell him the
story about my kid and then as I'm
telling him I'm going is this going to
sound weird like am I gonna sound like a
stalker like is this gonna and as I'm
telling them um he starts to cry
and so it choked him up he's a very
emotional guy yeah you got Liam Neeson
to cry because she named your kid out
and then Liam Neeson had my my mother
and my kids come to Canada when we were
shooting to Greg because he wanted to
meet Little Liam and and I got pictures
of my mother fawning over Liam